a series of events called the menstrual
cycle happens about once every month to
prepare a woman's body for pregnancy
changing levels of natural chemicals in
the bloodstream called hormones control
these events
the reproductive organs affected by
these hormones include the vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
the ovaries produce two main hormones
called estrogen and progesterone
as the level of estrogen begins to rise
it causes the normally thick mucus
inside the cervix to thin out
estrogen also triggers other hormones to
cause one of the ovaries to release an
egg this process is called ovulation
if a woman has sex during this time a
man's reproductive cells called sperm
can pass through the thinner more
receptive mucus to fertilize an egg
in the uterus estrogen has caused the
lining to thicken which has prepared it
to receive a fertilized egg
Rising progesterone levels cause glands
in the lining to make fluid that feeds
the fertilized egg
progesterone also causes the thinned out
mucus in the cervix to become thick
again which helps to prevent sperm from
passing through
if an egg hasn't been fertilized or
doesn't implant in the uterine lining
the levels of both estrogen and
progesterone Begin to Fall
this drop in hormone levels causes
menstruation a process where the uterus
sheds its inner tissue lining and blood
through the cervix and into the vagina
if you don't want to get pregnant you
may decide to use a type of birth
control
one type of birth control is the
progestin shot it prevents pregnancy for
up to three months
you get the shot in the muscles of your
upper arm or buttocks
if it's been more than 15 weeks since
your last shot you will need to use a
backup method of birth control for the
first week after getting your next shot
the shot contains a synthetic hormone
similar to Progesterone called progestin
in high enough levels progestin stops
the ovaries from releasing eggs when
there is no egg available to fertilize a
woman can't get pregnant
progestin also prevents pregnancy by
keeping the mucus in the cervix thick
enough so sperm can't get through it
a Third Way progestin prevents pregnancy
involves its influence on the lining of
the uterus
in contrast to Natural progesterone
progestin is slightly different
chemically
over time it makes the uterine lining
thinner instead of thicker
as a result if fertilization of an egg
were to take place the lining would
likely be too thin for the fertilized
egg to successfully implant in the
uterus so it would pass out of the body
with the next menstrual period
side effects of the birth control shot
may include
changes in your menstrual cycle
extra menstrual bleeding or spotting
loss of bone density
breast tenderness
weight gain
headaches
nervousness
and dizziness
if you get a birth control shot on time
every three months it's 99 effective at
preventing pregnancy
this means about one out of a hundred
women will become pregnant each year
using this form of birth control
but with typical use it's 94 effective
at preventing pregnancy
this means about six out of a hundred
women will become pregnant each year if
they don't always get their shot on time
to find out more about the birth control
shot talk to your health care provider